ich muss nicht gleich bei türmen kuban
entschuldigen aber es geht jetzt um die
cdu und zwar verstehe ich nicht was in
dieser partei seit der krachenden
wahlniederlage abgeht eigentlich müsste
man hier sagen wir machen jetzt einen
kompletten neustart und zwar so richtig
da müsste jemand sagen ich will diese
partei anführen stattdessen hören wir
nur andeutung von ihren sparen oder von
friedrich merz von carsten linnemann
alle lauern so ein bisschen und warten
ab und überlassen dem diesen neustart an
mit laschet der im moderieren will armin
laschet hätte eigentlich am 26 september
am sonntagabend als dieser cdu balken
bei 24% steckenblieb sagen sollen ich
bin weg und wenn er sich selbst gesagt
hätte dann hätte es zumindest
irgendjemand erster partei sagen müssen
und jetzt wird dieser ganze neustart
prozess armin laschet überlassen und dem
bundesvorstand man will sich jetzt auf
eine kompromisslösung einigen also die
leute die die partei jetzt gegen die
wand gefahren haben die sollen auch den
neustart organisieren für mich ist die
cdu gerade wirklich leider eine partei
ohne mumm und
dann bin ich ja schon angesprochen von
daher werde ich natürlich auch gerne
wieder wir haben ein klares verfahren
wir werden jetzt mit den
kreisvorsitzenden darüber sprechen wie
sie zum thema mitgliederbefragung stehen
glaubt es hinlänglich bekannt dass die
junge union das thema
mitgliederbefragung immer sehr sehr
stark nach vorne getrieben hat und
irgendwie schwebt ja über uns so ein
damoklesschwert es ist dieses gefühl da
ob es wirklich stimmt ist eine andere
frage aber das dreimal in den letzten
zwei jahren bei akasaba armin laschet
und auch bei der frage der
kanzlerkandidatur
gegen die basis entschieden worden wäre
und deswegen glaube ich dass wir jetzt
gut daran tun auch die mitglieder zu
befragen was sie denn wollen und
deswegen ist das glaube ich auch das
richtige verfahren um am ende einen
neuen parteivorsitzenden ein neue
parteivorsitzende man weiß ja nicht ob
sich auf frauen am ende dann bewerben
dann auch zu finden ja sie haben einen
interessanten punkt gesagt und zwar
dreimal wurde gegen den willen der basis
entschieden vermeintlich ja aber wer ist
dafür verantwortlich
fällt der name einem weiher am ende hat
das der am ende hat das der parteitag
entschieden beziehungsweise der
bundesvorstand das waren die drei
entscheidung aber wenn das so klar war
was der wille der basis war ich sage
nicht ich weiß nicht ob das ich weiß
nicht ob es so ist dieses ist dieses
gefühl was immer wieder publiziert wird
was immer wieder nach außen tragen würde
und am ende weiß ich nicht ich es ist
ein ist eine gefühlte wahrheit ja aber
und deswegen diese gefühlte wahrheit ich
glaube dass wir gut daran tun jetzt zu
sagen wir fragen die mitglieder einmal
um danach auch zu wissen was sie denn
wirklich wollen was mich persönlich sehr
sehr interessiert darüber habe ich heute
niemand gesprochen was ist denn jetzt in
der zukunft eigentlich die rolle von
paul signac also aktuell kriegt ja
irgendwie also alle laschen ist ja
sowieso ganz unten wer ist ja wirklich
auf denen wird ja nur noch draufgetreten
aber es haben ja auch andere bei dem
wahlkampf großen anteil gehabt wie sie
denn den zügen vom polzin ja das habe
ich mich heute mittag gefragt und dachte
zum glück kommt man ja und dann frage
ich dir danken ich halte polzin für ein
politisches talent und von daher wird er
sicherlich in zukunft haben innerhalb
der cdu
generalsekretär bleibt oder nicht dass
am ende auch immer eine frage dessen wer
was der parteivorsitzende vorschlägt
wäre es dann auch mal sein wird das
festjahr zwei jahre stil der cdu die
mitglieder zu befragen wieso eigentlich
wie kommen sie darauf
die sowie darauf kommen ja ich meine es
war aber auch noch nie so dass die cdu
24 hatte wir sind in einer besonderen
situation keine zusammen deswegen und
deswegen muss man sich aber auch die
frage stellen also 11 der kernthemen
warum wir eben diese wahl auf verloren
haben aus meiner sicht ist das werk eine
motivierte basis hatten und wenn die
eigenen 600.000 unionswähler nicht
überzeugt sind und nicht draußen sind
und motiviert sind dann wird es
natürlich auch schwierig macht sich
millionen deutsche zu überzeugen und
deswegen jede sachfrage dann eben wieder
einen gewissen motivationsschub zu geben
sie haben doch die funktionäre in den
parteivorsitzenden gewählt das heißt so
wie sie die trauen sich das jetzt nicht
mehr zu jetzt fragen sie die mitglieder
also ich habe bin ich habe immer eine
wahl getroffen für mich selber oder aber
eben als j ufer sitzen habe das ja auch
mal sehr deutlich gemacht dass wir als
junge union auch beim letzten mal mit
dem pitch wo wir alle drei sich
vorstellen lassen haben und wurde an
unsere mitglieder abgestimmt haben
damals ist friedrich merz rausgekommen
und ich habe als vorsitzender auf dem
parteitag auch dann friedrich merz
gewählt weil ich der weil ich der
überzeugung war dass es richtig ist da
auch als vorsitzender klar die stimme zu
erheben und dem ihr die stimme zu geben
der auch von der jungen union getragen
wird also ich muss ihr etwas so weit
sein und ich muss etwas positives über
die cdu sei ich verstehe das ja mit
einem gewissen staunen wie jetzt einfach
von allen seiten diese cdu auch von
ihnen übrigens
systematisch zerfleischt wird also die
wartezeit durch den fleischwolf gedreht
ist schon ziemlich von anfang an hat ja
das zdf und andere öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehen haben wir diese
lange periode von herrn laschet
sozusagen zum weltereignis hochgestellt
das also wirklich niemand das übersehen
konnte wurde das ins großhirn dir
einmassiert durch pausenlose
berichterstattung dann hatten wir ja den
kolleg den kollegen in münchen den er
sozusagen mit dem flammenwerfer und
hackl diesem jahr in richtung seine
charmeoffensive gemacht hat in richtung
laschet und und und natürlich auch mit
den medien diese cdu hat er sicher
fehler gemacht da haben wir darüber
gesprochen da gibt es viele dinge aber
am ende des tages muss man doch hier das
kind nicht mit dem bade ausschütten ich
sage nach wie vor für mich das dümmste
ist wie die cdu ihrem vorsitzenden
laschet in den rücken gefallen ist ich
meine die jamaika option ist doch groß
wie deutschland wie für die grünen wie
für die fdp die viel bessere option der
einzige der das wirklich realisiert hat
ist armin laschet aber alle fallen ihm
in den rücken ich sage nochmals der mann
hat fehler gemacht okay nobody's perfect
aber die cdu wird jetzt also unter ihrem
wert verkauft und spiegelbildlich dazu
steht dann erst aus diese übertragen
grundlose napoleon ist sie bedauerte er
ja nicht ist also aber jetzt endlich
kanzler und handlichkeit sondiert
jamaika sieht gerade aus weiter ferne
oder abfälle absolut ich glaube dass bei
jamaika armin laschet nicht erkannt hat
was das beste für das land ist sondern
auf das tun was das einzig mögliche noch
für ihn ist und zwar kanzleramt war
ansonsten hat er halt gar nichts ich
glaube dass herr lautet nach wie vor
massiv unterschätzt wird auch auf die
gefahr hin dass ihr jetzt nur noch
innerlich den kopf schüttelt ich denke
dass er für mich also das ist mein
persönlicher eindruck sie könnten das
natürlich bestätigt verwerfen ich glaube
auch laschet ist tatsächlich ein
politiker der erstaunlich wenig um sich
gedacht hat in diesem ganzen wahlkampf
denn er hat zum beispiel gesagt ich
trete als ministerpräsident in nrw
zurück hat ein opfer hat etwas aufs
spiel gesetzt
das hat das nicht gemacht sondern auch
nicht gemacht und da muss ich aber sagen
bevor wir uns jetzt einfach von diesen
trend mitreißen lassen bei herrn lage
bei den gegner nach unten zu zeigen ich
denke und ich bleibe bei meiner aussage
die hier gemacht habe für mich ist das
der mann mit der größten substanz in
diesem wahlkampf vielleicht auch schon
einige über den wahlkampf und das hat
sich seine ich teile ihre einschätzung
dass armin laschet jemand ist dem immer
die zu der zusammenhalt der partei und
der zusammenhalt deutschlands wichtiger
war als seine eigene person vollkommen
der chor
nichtsdestotrotz muss man halt sagen wir
haben am ende 24 prozent gut und die spd
26 toren das ist schon da ist schon am
ende auch ein unterschied und man muss
dann auch in demut anerkennen dass der
ball jetzt vielleicht erstmal im
spielfeld von von olaf scholz saskia
esken und norbert walter borjans liegt
wenn sie es schaffen eine regierung zu
bilden okay aber wenn sie es nicht
schaffen dann wird die union auch bereit
stehen für eine jamaika koalition und
das liegt aber jetzt auch am ende
zwischen an den drei koalitionäre
[Musik]